all right looks like we're
now live for the next uh storytelling
with Sadler and just to remind everybody
what this is I read some of my favorite
short stories of all time many of which
I first read as a child or a teenager or
in the army or as a college student and
this one is actually for today one that
I did I think maybe first read in high
school or in college it is one of the
very first Earthsea stories and I do
want to show you where it's coming from
I've got this massive Tom and Omnibus
volume that I use when I teach and talk
about Ursula K Le Guin the books of
Earthsea it's really quite a lovely
volume to have and way in the back along
with trials versus artwork we have the
story the rule of names now this is one
of the stories of Earthsea that Ursula
Kayla green wrote before you know even a
wizard of Earthsea it's part of how she
is
establishing the very narrative setting
you could say of this fantasy world that
will eventually become quite rich and
developed so
with no further to do let me get started
and then after I'm finished I'll tell
you what I really like about this story
we can do some discussion you can leave
comments and questions on the side but
let's uh let's kind of dip into the
storytelling aspect of it right off the
bat and then we'll we'll analyze it and
discuss it
so the rule of names by Ursula k leguin
Mr Underhill came out from under his
Hill smiling and breathing hard every
breath shot out of his nostrils as a
double puff of steam Snow White in the
morning sunshine Mr Underhill looked up
at the bright December sky and smiled
wider than ever showing Snow White Teeth
then he went down to the Village
morning Mr Underhill said the villagers
as he passed them in the Narrow Street
between houses with conical overhanging
roofs like the red fat caps of
toadstools morning morning he replied to
each it was of course bad luck to wish
anyone a good morning a simple statement
of the time of day was quite enough in a
place so permeated with influences as
satin's Island where a careless
adjective might change the weather for a
week all of them spoke to him some with
affection some with affectionate disdain
he was all the little island had in the
way of a wizard and so deserved respect
but how could you respect a little fat
man of 50 who waddled along with his
toes turned in breathing Steam and
smiling he was no great shakes as a
Workman early either his fireworks were
fairly elaborate but his elixirs were
weak
um warts that he Charmed off frequently
reappeared after three days Tomatoes he
Enchanted grew no bigger than
cantaloupes and those rare times when a
strange ship stopped at Saturn's Harbor
Mr Underhill always stayed under his
Hill for fear he explained of the evil
eye
he was in other words a wizard the way
wall-eyed Gan was a carpenter by default
the villagers made with badly hung doors
and inefficient spells for this
generation and relieved their annoyance
by treating Mr Underhill quite
familiarly as a mere fellow villager
they even asked him to dinner
once he asked some of them to dinner and
served a splendid repairs with Crystal
silver damask roast Goose sparkling
Andreas 1639 and plum pudding with hard
sauce but he was so nervous all through
the meal that it took the joy out of it
and besides everyone was hungry again
half an hour afterwards
he did not like anyone to visit his cave
not even the anter room Beyond which in
fact nobody had ever gone
when he saw people approaching the hill
he always came out trotting to meet them
let's sit out here under the pine trees
he would say smiling and waving towards
the fur Grove or if it was raining let's
go have a drink at the end eh although
everyone knew he'd drink nothing
stronger than well water
some of the village children teased by
that lock cave poked and prodded and
pried and made rage while Mr Underhill
was away but the small door that led
into the inner chamber was Spell shut
and it seemed for once to Be an
Effective spell
once a couple of boys thinking the
wizard was over in the West Shore curing
Mrs runa's sick donkey brought a crowbar
and a hatchet up there but the first
whack of the hatchet on the door there
came a roar of wrath from inside and a
cloud of purple steam Mr Underhill had
got home early the boys fled he did not
come out and the boys came to no harm
though they said you couldn't believe
what a huge hooting howling hissing
horrible Bellow that little fat man
could make until he had heard it
his business in town this day was three
dozen fresh eggs and a pound of liver
also a stop at Sea Captain's foganos
Cottage to renew the seeing charm on the
old man's eyes quite useless when
applied to a case of detached retina but
Mr Underhill kept trying and finally a
chat with old goody gold the concertina
makers Widow Mr underhill's friends were
mostly old people he was timid with the
strong young men of the village and the
girls were shy of him
he makes me nervous he smiles so much
they all said pouting twisting silky
ringlets around a finger nervous was a
newfangled word and their mothers all
grew replied grimly nervous my foot
silliness is the word for it Mr
Underhill is a very irrespectable wizard
after leaving goody gold Mr Underhill
passed by the school which was being
held this day out on the common since no
one on Saturn's Island was literate
there were no books to learn from and no
deaths to carve initials on and no
blackboards to erase and in fact no
schoolhouse
on rainy days the children met in the
loft of the communal barn and got hay in
their pants on sunny days the school
teacher Palani took them anywhere she
felt like today is surrounded by 30
interested children under 12 and 40
uninterested sheep under five she was
teaching an important item on the
curriculum the rule of names
Mr Underhill smiling shyly paused to
listen and watch
Palani a plump pretty girl of 20 made a
Charming picture there in the wintry
sunlight sheep and children around her a
leafless oak above her and behind her
the dunes and sea and clear pale Sky she
spoke earnestly her face flushed Pink by
wind and words now you know the rule of
names already children there are two and
they're the same on every island in the
world what's one of them
it ain't polite to ask anyone what his
name is shouted a fat quick boy
interrupted by a little girl shrieking
you could never tell your own name to
nobody my ma says
yes Suba yes poppy dear don't Screech
that's right you never ask anybody his
name you never tell your own
now think about that a minute and tell
me why we call our wizard Mr Underhill
she smiled across the curly heads in the
woolly backs at Mr Underhill who beamed
and nervously clutched his sack of eggs
because he lives under a hill seven half
the children but is it his true name
no said the fat boy echoed by little
poppy shrieking no how do you know it's
not
because he came here all alone and so
there wasn't anybody knew his true name
so they couldn't tell us and he couldn't
very good super poppy don't shout that's
right even a wizard can't tell his true
name when you children are through
school and go through the passage you'll
leave your child names behind and keep
only your true names which you must
never ask for and never give away why is
that the rule
the children were silent the Sheep
bleeded gently Mr Underhill answered the
question because the name is the thing
he said in his shy soft husky voice and
the true name is the true thing
to speak the name is to control the
thing am I right School mistress
she smiled and curtsied evidently a
little embarrassed by his participation
and he trotted off towards his Hill
clutching his eggs to his bosom somehow
the minutes spent watching Palani and
the children had made him very hungry he
locked his inner door behind him with a
hasty incantation but there must have
been a leak or two in the spell so for
soon the bear enter room in the cave was
rich with the smell of frying eggs and
sizzling liver
the wind that day was light and fresh
out of the West and honored at noon a
little boat came skimming the bright
waves into Saturn's Harbor even as it
rounded the point a sharp-eyed boy
spotted it and knowing like every child
on the island every sail and Spar of the
40 fishing boats of 40 boats of the
fishing fleet he ran down the street
calling out a foreign boat a foreign
boat very seldom was the lonely Isle
visited by a boat from some equally
lonely aisle of the East reach or an
adventurous Trader from the archipelago
by the time the boat was at the pier
half the village was there to greet it
and the fishermen were following it
homewards and cow herds and clam diggers
and Herb unters were puffing up all down
the rocky hills heading toward the
harbor but Mr underhill's door stayed
shut
there was only one man aboard the boat
old sea captain phageno when they told
him that uh Drew down a bristle of white
brows over his unseeing eyes there's
only one kind of man he said that sails
the outer reach alone a wizard or a
warlock or a mage
so the villagers were breathless hoping
for once in their lives to see a mage
one of the mighty white magicians of the
rich towered crowded inner islands of
the archipelago they were disappointed
vote and leaped ashore like any sailor
glad to have made Port he introduced
himself at once as a sea Peddler but
when they told sea captain phagano that
he carried an oak and walking stick
about with him the old man noddered two
wizards one time and as well snapshot
like an old carps
The Stranger could not give him give
them his name they gave him one right
away Blackbeard and they gave him plenty
of attention he had a small mixed cargo
of cloth and sandals and piss wee
feathers for trimming cloaks and cheap
incense and levity stones and fine herbs
and glass beads from venue the usual
Peddler's lot
everyone on Saturn's Island came to look
to chat with the Voyager and perhaps to
buy something just to remember him by
cackled goody gold who like all the
women and girls of the village was
smitten with Blackbeard's bold good
looks all the boys hung about him too to
hear him tell of this voyages to far
strange islands of the reach or describe
to describe the great Rich islands of
the archipelago the inner Lanes the road
studs white with ships and the golden
roofs of hovnor
the men willingly listened to his tales
but some of them wondered why a traitor
should sail alone and kept their eyes
thoughtfully on his Oaken staff
but all this time Mr Underhill stayed
under his Hill
first island I've seen that had no
wizard said Blackbeard one evening to
goody gold who'd invited him and her
nephew and Palani in for a cup of Rush
wash tea what do you do when you get a
toothache or the cow goes dry
well we've got Mr Underhill said the old
woman for what that's worth moderate her
nephew Bert and then blush purple and
Spilled his tea Bert was a fisherman a
large Brave wordless young man he loved
the school mistress but the nearest he'd
come to telling her of his love was to
give baskets of fresh mackerel to her
father's cook oh you do have a wizard
Blackbeard asked is he invisible
no he's just very shy said Palani you've
only been here a week you know and we
see so few strangers here she also
blushed a little but did not spill her
tea Blackbeard smiled at her he's a good
Stan sentence man then a
no said goody gold no more than you are
another cup nebby keep it in the cup
this time no my dear he came in for a
little bit of a boat came in on a little
bit of a boat four years ago was it just
a day after the end of the Shad run I
recall for they were taking up the Nets
in East Creek and pondy Cowherd broke
his leg that very morning five years ago
it must be no no four no five it is Twas
the year the garlic didn't sprout so he
sails in on a bit of a Sloop loaded up
with great chests and boxes and says to
see Captain phagano who wasn't blind
then though old enough goodness to be
blind twice over I here tell you've got
no no wizard no warlock at all might you
be wanting one
indeed if the Magic's white said the
captain and before you could say
cuttlefish Mr Underhill had settled down
in the cave under the hill and was
Charming the mange off goodie belto's
cat though the fur grew in Gray and it
was an orange cat queer looking thing it
was after that it died last winter in
the cold spell goodie belto took on so
at the cat's death poor thing worse than
winter man was drowned in the long Banks
the year of the long airing runs when
nevy bird here was just a babe in
petticoats here Bert spilled his tea
again and Blackbeard grinned but goody
gold proceeded undismaned and talked
until Nightfall
next day Blackbeard was down at the pier
seeing after the sprung board in his
boat which seemed to take a long time
fixing and as usual drawing the
taciturned sadness men into talk now
which of these is your Wizard's craft he
asked or has he got one of the those the
Mages fold up into a walnut shell when
they're not using it
knee said a solid fisherman she's up in
his cave under Hill
he carried the boat he came in up to his
cave I clear up I helped heavier as lead
she was full loop with great boxes and
they full up with boxes of books of
spells he says heavier as lead she was
and the solid fisherman turned his back
sighing solidly
goody Gold's nephew mending a net nearby
looked up from his work and asked with
equal solidity would you like to meet Mr
Underhill Maybe
Blackbeard returned Bert's look clever
black eyes met candid blue ones for a
long moment then Blackbeard smiled and
said yes will you take me up to Hilbert
I when I'm done with this said the
fisherman and when the net was mended he
and the archipelagon set off up the
Village Street towards the high Green
Hill above it but as they cross the
common Blackbeard said hold on a while
Fred Bert I have a tail to tell you
before we meet your wizard tell away
says Bert sitting down in the shade of a
live oak
it's a story that started a hundred
years ago and it isn't finished yet
though it soon will be very soon
in the very heart of the archipelago
where the Island's crowd thick as flies
on honey there's a little aisle called
pendor the sea Lords of pendor were
Mighty Men in the old days of War before
the league Loot and Ransom and tribute
came pouring into pendor and they
gathered a great treasure there long ago
then from somewhere away out in the west
reach where dragons breed on the lava
Isles came one day a very Mighty dragon
not one of those overgrown lizards most
of you out of reachful call dragons but
a big black winged wise cunning Monster
full of strength and subtlety and like
all dragons loving gold and precious
stones above all things he killed the
Sea Lord and soldiers and the people of
pendor fled in their ships by night they
all fled away and left the dragon coiled
up in Pandora towers and there he stayed
for a hundred years dragging a scaly
belly over the emerald sand Sapphires
and coins of gold coming forth only in
once a year in a year or two when he
must eat he'd raid nearby islands for
his food you know what dragons eat
Bert nodded and said in a whisper
maidens
Right Said Blackbeard well that couldn't
be endured forever nor the thought of
him sitting on all that treasure so
after the league grew strong and the
archipelago wasn't so busy with Wars and
piracy it was decided to attack pendor
drive out the dragon and get the gold
and jewels for the treasury of the
league they're forever wanting money the
league is so a huge Fleet gathered from
50 islands and seven Mages stood in the
prowse of the seven strongest ships and
they sailed towards pendor they got
there
they landed nothing stirred
the houses all stood empty the dishes on
the tables full of 100 years dust the
bones of the old Sea Lord and his men
lay about in the castle courts and on
the stairs and the tower rooms reeked of
dragon but there was no dragon and no
treasure not a diamond the size of a
poppy seed not a single silver bead
knowing he couldn't stand up to seven
Mages the dragon had skipped out they
tracked him and found he'd flown to a
deserted island up north called udrath
they followed his Trail there and what
did they find bones again his bones the
dragon but no treasure
a wizard some unknown wizard from
somewhere must have met him
single-handed and defeated him and then
made off of the treasure right under the
League's nose
the fishermen listened attentive and
expressionless now that must have been a
powerful wizard and a clever one first
to kill a dragon and second to get off
without leaving a trace the Lords and
mages of the archipelago couldn't track
him at all neither where he'd come from
nor he where he'd made off to they were
about to give up that was last spring
I'd been on a three-year Voyage up in
the north North reach and got back about
that time and they asked me to help him
find help them find the unknown wizard
that was clever of them
because I'm not only a wizard myself as
I think some of the Wolves here have
guessed but I'm also a descendant of the
Lords of pendor
though that treasure is mine it's mine
and it knows that it's mine those fools
of the league couldn't find it because
it's not theirs it belongs to the house
of Pender and the great Emerald the star
of the hold in all key the green stone
knows its Master behold Blackbeard
raised his Oaken staff and cried aloud
and I'll inoculi the tip of the staff
began to grow green of fiery green
Radiance a dazzling Haze the color of
April grass and at the same moment the
staff tipped in the Wizard's hand
leaning slanting till it pointed
straight at the side of the Hill
above them
it wasn't so bright a glow far away and
havner Blackbeard murmured but the staff
pointed true
and I'll kill answered when I called the
jewel knows its master and I know the
thief and I shall conquer him he's a
mighty wizard who could overcome a
dragon but I am mightier do you want to
know why oaf
because I know his name
as Blackbeard's tone got more arrogant
bird had looked duller and duller
blanker and blanker but at this he gave
a twitch shut his mouth and stared at
the archipelagon
how did you learn it he asked very
slowly Blackbeard grinned and did not
answer
black magic how else
Bert looked pale and said nothing I am
the Sea Lord of pendor oaf and I will
have the gold my father's one and The
Jewels my mother's War and the
greenstone for they are mine
now you can go tell your village boobies
the whole story after I've defeated this
Wizard and gone wait here or or you
could come and watch
if you're not afraid you'll never get
the chance again to see a great wizard
in all his power
Blackbeard turned and without a backward
glance Strode up the hill towards the
entrance of the cave
very slowly Bert followed a good
distance from the cave he stopped sat
down under a Hawthorne tree and watched
the archipelagon had stopped a stiff
dark figure alone on the swell green of
the hill before the gaping cave mouth he
stood perfectly still
all at once he swung his staff up over
his head and the emerald Radiance shown
about him as he shouted thief thief of
the horde of Pandora come forth
there was a crash as of dropped Crockery
from inside the cave and a lot of dust
came spewing out scared Bert ducked when
he looked again he saw Blackbird beard
Still Standing motionless and at the
mouth of the cave Dusty and disheveled
stood Mr Underhill he looked small and
pitiful with his toes turned in as usual
and his little bow legs and black tights
and no staff he never had one Bert
suddenly thought Mr Underhill spoke
who are you
he asked in his husky little voice I am
the Sea Lord of pendor thief come to
claim my treasure
at that Mr Underhill slowly turned pink
as he always did when people were rude
to him but then he turned something else
he turned yellow his hair bristled out
he gave a coughing Roar and was a yellow
lion leaping down the hill at Blackbeard
white fangs gleaming but Blackbeard no
longer stood there a gigantic tiger
color of night and lightning bounded to
meet him the lion was gone below the
cave all of a sudden stood a high Grove
of trees black in the winter Sunshine
the tiger checking himself in mid leap
just before he entered the shadow of the
trees caught fire in the air became a
tongue of flame lashing out at the dry
black branches but where the trees had
stood a sudden cataract leap from the
hillside an arch of silvery crashing
water thundering down on the fire but
the fire was gone for just a moment
before the fisherman's staring Eyes Two
Hills Rose a green one he knew and a new
one a bare Brown hillock ready to drink
up the rushing waterfall that passed so
quickly it made Bert blink and after
blinking he blinked again and moaned for
what he saw now was a great deal worse
where the Cataract had been they're
hovered a dragon
black wings darkened all the hill steel
claws reached groping and from the dark
scaly gaping lips fire and steam showed
out beneath the Monstrous creature stood
Blackbeard laughing take any shape you
please miss little Mr underhilly taunted
I can match you but the game grows
tiresome I want to look upon my treasure
upon inocul now big dragon Little Wizard
take your true shape I command you by
the power of your true name yavod
Bert could not move at all not even to
Blink he cowered staring whether he
could whether he could or not he saw the
black dragon hang there in the air above
Blackbeard he saw the fire lick like
many tongues from the scaly mouth his
steamed jet from the red nostrils he saw
Blackbeard's face grow white white as
chalk and the beard fringed lips
trembling
your name is yavod
yes
set a great husky hissing voice my true
name is you vote
and my true shape
is this shape
but the dragon was killed they found
dragon bones on udrath Island
that was another Dragon said the dragon
and swooped like a hawk Talons
outstretched and Bert shut his eyes
when he opened them the sky was clear
the hillside empty except for a reddish
blackish trampled spot and a few Talon
marks on the grass
Bert the fisherman got to his feet and
ran he ran across the common scattering
sheep to right and left and straight
down to the Village Street to palani's
Father's House Palani was out in the
garden weeding the nasturtiums come with
me Bert Gast she stared he grabbed her
wrist and dragged her with him she
screeched a little but did not resist he
ran with her straight to the pier pushed
her into his fishing Sloop the queen he
untied the painter took up the oars and
took off rowing like a demon the last
that Saturn Island saw of him in Palani
was the Queenie sail Vanishing in the
direction of the nearest Island Westward
the villagers thought they would never
stop talking about it how goody Gold's
nephew bird had lost his mind and sailed
off at the school mistress on the very
same day that the Peddler Blackbeard
disappeared Without a Trace leaving all
his feathers and Beads behind
but they did stop talking about it three
days later
they had other things to talk about when
Mr Underhill finally came out of his
cave
Mr Underhill had decided that since his
true name was no longer a secret he may
as well drop his disguise
walking was a lot harder than flying and
besides it was a long long time since he
had had a real meal
that is the end
of this really wonderful Story by Ursula
K Le Guin the rule of names one of the
first of the earth sea tales and you
notice the twist ending right that was
another dragon and uh Blackbeard you
know was quite the
Mage and
Sea Lord but really wasn't up for
meeting a dragon face to face so I read
that in uh the Anthology where it was
found the winds 12 quarters which um I
bought at a used bookstore and I think I
read it maybe in the army or in high
school or you know definitely read it
and reread it in college
and I think it's a great story when I
teach Ursula Kayla Queen's Earthsea
stuff there's six big books of Earth see
I actually use this and one other very
early story to introduce the students to
this world because it it's got such a
great take on what names mean you know
it's being info dumped as we say today
right by uh Mr Underhill and the teacher
um and we get an idea about why names
actually matter what you can do with
them and how you can get them black
magic for example or tricking somebody
into telling you their name and this is
going to become a really significant
part of Earthsea as a whole and what
magic does in Earthsea in all of the
later stories so uh that's probably
enough from me about this this cool
story
I'd be interested to see what other
people have to say about it I'll answer
any questions that you've got we've got
plenty of time if people want to leave
them they're in the chat I will bring
them up but also
get myself some of the good Stone Creek
local coffee that we have here so uh
actually I'd be interested too who's
read this story before
um and who has read within the Earthsea
books that the story is um situated
within and introducing us to it sort of
our gateway drug to Le guin's Earth see
one of the really
first-rate fantasy locations in books
and stories that are actually not that
long you know Ursa K leguin can do in
150 pages with a lot of other authors
struggle to do and
450 pages so
all right so enough out of me what have
you got what do you want to say
I'll answer questions address comments
um
not seeing any yet but hopefully people
are writing something
otherwise it'll be a rather short
session on our part
after this since I'm actually feeling
better from my illness that I had I'm
going to be visiting uh almost home cat
shelter where I volunteer and seeing the
new kittens that got brought in
um but any questions comments
all right so Nora says thank you for
reading this uh I never heard of this
book however I know this whole concept
is relevant right now yeah so like I
mentioned it's it's uh part of you can
find it in this massive Omnibus volume
that includes the six books of Earthsea
wizard of earthy the tombs of ottawan
and uh the farthest Shore the first
Trilogy Then followed by tohanu Tales of
Earthsea which is a set of five short
stories and a Glock sort of like a
history of Earthsea and then the final
uh one which is
um the other wind
but these two uh Stories the rule of
names and
um
the uh
here we go word of unbinding also you
know connected up with with names as
well so yeah here's here's the book easy
enough to find you just type in the book
books of Earthsea and it's very nicely
Illustrated you see this uh
on the cover right that's Charles vess
who is commissioned to do all sorts of
cool illustrations for the stories and
Ursula K the queen you know got to got
to interact with him about that so
uh any other questions comments people
want to make
[Music]
I will say well we're waiting for that
I've decided that
um the next story that I want to do uh
for September is one uh we've done a few
cat themed ones I'm going to do another
cat themed one namely the cats of ulthar
by H.P Lovecraft a really interesting
story not a cosmic Horror Story like
most of his are but a more
straightforward fantasy story so all
right well I'm not seeing any further
questions or comments so I think we'll
probably wrap this up we do these story
readings once a month it's always my
favorite short stories that I'm hoping
to introduce people to so you know like
with Nora if you haven't heard of this
go check out Ursula Kayla green and I
think you'll probably find her stuff
quite interesting and enjoyable so I
hope everybody has a great rest of the
day wherever you happen to be morning
afternoon night time and I'll see you
all next time